choose a Shonda Rhimes character to hang
out with for the day and we have Olivia
Pope Scandal Derek from Gray's Anatomy
annalize from How To Get Away With
Murder Maya from stations Oliver from
How To Get Away With Murder and
Christina from Gray's Anatomy that's a
difficult one
you went Derek straight away no no sorry
sorry
no no and you were wrong I was like Wow
Olivia Pope I'm gonna go with Maya
that's why the one that I know the least
about but I feel like I can do anything
I would be safe yeah oh yeah that is
true
and they're not real oh gosh it is tough
okay it be between Olivia and Christina
I feel like me and Olivia could have
like a big glass of wine together you
know and just like sit on her nice DC
couch yeah get all the tea how big is
this glass of wine like it's like
trademark that like the thing is like
the Goblet yeah